in our series school matters new
research shows a child's age compared to
their classmates could impact their
mental and behavioral health a study in
JAMA Pediatrics looked at data for more
than a million kids aged 14 to 15
researchers in Britain found the
youngest children in the class have a
roughly 30% higher chance of developing
depression compared to their oldest
peers in the same class and apart from
depression they also have an increased
chance of being diagnosed with ADHD and
learning disabilities psychologist and
CBS News contributor ELISA d'amour is
here Lisa good morning as you said
everyone has an opinion about this
because we all fall somewhere on the
calendar yeah why might younger students
be more likely to have symptoms of
depression and ADHD so what we have to
remember is development unfolds on its
own time
you can't force development forward so
that means that if a child is relatively
immature in the class maybe because of
age they will not necessarily have the
skills for attention that the older kids
will have so they may be more likely to
show up with questions about whether or
not they have ADHD the tricky thing is
this is an issue for parents that may
develop when the kids in fifth sixth
seventh eighth grade but the decision
started in kindergarten maybe younger
yeah it's true and we have to be careful
because if we push kids ahead or they're
very young in the class they can feel a
step behind both intellectually and also
socially you know social cueing among
kids is pretty subtle yeah
and so for kids who are young there can
be an awareness that they're missing out
or they don't really understand the
social landscape but they don't know
what they're missing or they don't know
how to fit in and it can be really hard
on their self-esteem and we think that
can open the door to questions so to
make that decision if they have to make
the decision should I hold you back or
not what factors should go into making a
decision like that so there's a lot of
the option a lot we can do to get this
right first of all we have to remember
development is multifaceted there is
intellectual development there's social
development there's emotional
development there's physical development
you don't want one of those driving the
decision so if someone might say my
four-year-old reads put them ahead but
if the four-year-old can't share we
should reconsider similarly you can have
a kid who's too
quickly skilled socially but lacking
academically so look at the whole
picture the other thing I will say is
ask the teachers if your child's a
preschooler you have preschool teachers
who have watched your child all year you
know your preschooler they are comparing
your children to hundreds of
preschoolers we also cannot be neutral
about our own children it's just it's
not a possibility and teachers have
actually seen your child in a classroom
setting yeah so if you're I'm sure I
would say to a teacher you know my kid
if she were your kid what would you do
in these situations and take that very
seriously teachers are experts in
childhood I think there's a natural
reluctance as a parent to acknowledge
your child may need to be held back but
the consequence is down the road if you
don't do it when you when you find out
you have to make I'm skipping the whole
back of grade it can be really serious
they can when parents and I are thinking
about this I always say err on the side
of caution give your child another year
of childhood if you're wrong we can
offer enrichment later if they're bored
in school we can offer enrichment later
if you push a child ahead and it's the
bad call
you are then looking at the possibility
of your child playing catch-up for the
rest of education or worse having to
repeat a grade right which is very
humiliating for a kid
then you're labeled for the rest of the
time you're at the school devastating
brilliance so I want to avoid that at
all costs
is there a zero is there a connection
between physical development and
emotional and behavioral development and
kids and is there a difference between
girls and boys so this is interesting so
obviously older kids are more likely to
be ahead physically in their development
which means better coordination and
especially for boys it can also
especially down the line have to do with
size and strength mm-hm so for boys who
are big and strong in a class there's
often a lot of social currency caught up
with that especially if they're good
athletes yeah so sometimes nobody really
notices the distinction and then puberty
hits and all of a sudden the kids who
are on the front edge of that have a lot
more social currency always in
particular and so it can be a very
weighty decision at age five when we
think about the implications down the
line
physical and emotional development
definitely aren't in tandem I mean it's
like with with 12 year olds it can be
like a airport with the planes taken off
where there's no air traffic control
yeah
it's a very good analogy very nice thank
you Lisa welcome good to see you